there's definitely masturbation
questions I know that and if there's not
then this is really awkward and I'm
saying that I have no idea what's coming
at me up there love balls balls dicks
hair I think these are really really
funny I'm sure there's gonna be
something about boners so give me
something about body hair he's gonna be
some pretty serious questions so here's
the list
why do men grow beards I feel like I can
speak to this a lot of them do it to
hide the ugly keeps your face warm it's
just like a lion's mane hiding I'm
hiding behind of a thought it's because
I'm just too lazy to shave less it lets
you channel a lumberjack spirit and I
really need it because everybody likes
beards oh my god well eirick why do you
go you've never done that before ever
I've very infrequently ghost it ghosting
is when you go out on a date or a couple
of dates with somebody and then instead
of breaking it off with them and like
being explicit about it you just vanish
like a ghost and pretend like nothing
ever happened
honestly it's just a way of avoiding
confrontation think people ghosts
because they avoid Maya Maya like mildly
uncomfortable situation they're like
it's common courtesy to like text back
just say not interested provide a little
closure a little basic human respect men
don't ghosts it's bad stop ghosting this
is a good question that I also want to
know the answer to this wants to be
close to you he just wants to talk to
you just wants to try to understand you
know you a little bit better if they're
making super consistent eye contact if
you complimenting you a lot but they're
laughing your joke that nobody else
they're not a hundred percent but I'd
say 90% if someone's asking you to hang
out what I wanted is like texting you a
lot or flirting
I don't understand how people can haul I
agree I'm with you on that way but I see
it happen all the time when I'm assuming
it's for attention because that's the
only way they're gonna get this woman's
attention is if they shout [ __ ] like
what makes you feel like this is okay or
normal
maybe they'll care if it's good you know
exactly an issue yeah like some woman is
registering them and some degree it's
dildo and it's disgusting men should
stop it's the moral of 2017
yeah insecure is such a strong word and
no one really likes I think of
themselves as insecure guys are insecure
at times they question their parents
they question how they speak I wish I
still had hair like that would be fun
I always think like people don't like me
I think the number one sin scared for me
would be physique because there's always
like any strong pressure for men to look
very muscular somebody commented on the
last video I can't believe the kids
wearing a hollister and I went out and
bought a whole new wardrobe after that
one comment when I did one of these
videos before the comments were like
predominantly about like how my dad
should have like taking me to the woods
more and like why the BuzzFeed have so
many gay boys and their videos and stuff
a lot of men are very insecure about
their masculinity and feel like they
need to exert it in some way shape or
form instead of just kind of being true
to who they are I mean I thought these
were some pretty good questions
hopefully people are depth phul I'm
assuming and one of the answers to some
of these questions which quite frankly
deserve an answer I think this list is
pretty thorough I mean this is a good
start to you know continue the
conversation of men's emotions I was
expecting like I love more about dick
size honestly there was there was
nothing about that yeah beer at that I
was thinking I go if I can bring balls
does something in that vicinity right